well here's the problem culture all of
this is psychology right so like I was
born the Soviet Union right and so like
for as much as China loves to talk about
it's capitalism there's plenty of
communist tendencies still in that
country there I'm an investor in a
company that can trust it and then
somebody wired into the government who
was competing with that app decided that
was a bad thing and I just disappeared
right that doesn't really happen as much
in the US right and so I think that
culturally we have to understand a lot
of differences for example nobody in
America cares about privacy let's start
with that we think we do but our
behavior shows we don't because we only
do things Americans really care about is
the health of their fairly and money and
both of those things have been solved
with a more open world not punishing for
example how many people here know that
credit card fraud in their life search
their hand write quite a few if every
one of these people didn't get their
money back they would give a [ __ ] about
privacy but they all got their money
back right and then when you look at
kidnapping or crime because of all media
companies now right that we can record
kidnapping is actually collapsing it
across the country because it's hard to
kidnap a kid in the [ __ ] ball at four
o'clock is between 900 pictures right
however so this is important as so what
that does is it allows us in America to
share to put out more stuff if you look
at the behavior in other places
there's countries in the Middle East
where people are very scared to share
something and even in China the
shareability
has very different things so culturally
there's so many variables we work with a
lot of global brands we spend a lot of
time understanding the slang the nuances
you know pop culture the us on Sundays
football pop culture India Sunday's
cricket there's all these variables but
basically call it that like slang right
it's just knowing the nuances you have
the north start when you're trying to
kind of achieve but if you are unable to
translate and culturally you lose so
there is no distribution now that
doesn't have a culture it happens for
platform the same picture doesn't do as
well on Facebook as it doesn't Pinterest
as doesn't Instagram as it does on
Twitter there's a very different context
to the person while they're looking a
twenty seven-year-old woman on Pinterest
looking at a picture she's window
shopping or the intent or aspiration to
buy what she's going through to stream
on Facebook she's keeping up with her
world you had the message totally
different if you want to sell based on
what platform she's on based on if she's
on mobile versus if she's on desktop so
we're grossly underestimated all these
context points we just think it you know
every the content is king that's
ludicrous content through the proper
context filter is king and that context
filter is takes a lot of data and
understanding like how many for example
I know that picture on Instagram with a
primary color red in the bottom left
corner
has a better chance of succeeding than
not right but that takes a lot of
testing and being in at that the reason
I know that is cuz we've managed 150
accounts and we have scale of metrics
and all we ever do knowing that Facebook
has all the data is we're trying to
figure out the creative data right how
many how many words in a post
how many hashtags on Instagram all these
different variables and it becomes
pretty endless when you go to
geo-targeting I mean America's segmented
if you use the word pop you know when
you oppose in South Carolina it will do
better than if you use the same word
soda in New York it will do better and
so you're going to the heavy some slang
marketing it's very intense when you go
to China America America France because
the cultures are fundamentally different
things messaging resonates very
differently you know u.s. is very
conservative when it comes to sex I can
tell you French posts that are risking
crushed right and so it's a lot of these
stereotypes that we've all heard think
they work but you know blanket just
taking something and posting it even if
you completely translate a word for it
never works because you took out the
context all you do is translate the
content